you betcha barbie i mean margot robbie
oh i'm having so much fun well bobby
we're just getting started margo and her
kin doll ryan gosling are matching head
to toe in these very 80s inspired
outfits on the set of the highly
anticipated live-action barbie flick
currently filming at la's venice beach
the pair sports bright neon yellow
skates with matching knee pads and of
course visors to block out that bright
california sun ryan is even rocking a
color-coordinated fanny pack so totally
tubular so fun but seems like it's not
all fun and games for barbie and ken
while filming on location at the
boardwalk shops ryan and margo make a
run for it which could be a hint at how
their characters nab margo's hot pink
western outfit we also got our first
listen to margot's spot on barbie girl
accent ready
the first look uh listen came while
margot shot scenes with co-star america
ferreira they also bladed by the beach
though america's outfit is a little more
understated than margo's it feels
wonderful
[Music]
of course this isn't the first time fans
have gotten a taste of the film due out
next year in april warner brothers
shared this pic of margot as the iconic
doll dressed in blue sitting in what
else a pink convertible i'm excited too
last year the actress teased e.t with
what fans can expect from the movie
expect the unexpected it's not going to
be whatever you're thinking it's not
it's not that and earlier this month
fans also got a look at ryan's kin
complete with washboard abs bleach
blonde hair and a sun-kissed tan so how
did the actor transform for the role
well co-star seemu liu spilled on ryan's
training routine he's definitely like a
gym in the morning gym after work kind
of guy and i just um you know as much as
i i believe that i do have a work ethic
i also
love
food
a lot
and you know just hearing little bits
and pieces about you know just his his
strict diet regimen and just like how
you know much emphasis he puts on taking
care of himself and his body i'm like i
i respect it i respect it i'm gonna have
some soda semu who's rumored to play a
different version of canon the flick
also promised plenty of fun colors for
the film which we've picked up on
through all these paparazzi shot sneak
peeks i feel like the less i tell you
the better because i feel like every
little piece of news that comes out to
tease people everyone just gets
progressively more confused and curious
as to what this movie is and i kind of
like that i feel like
i feel like july of next year when it
comes people are going to be really
really surprised um just fun just fun
colors like we're wearing bright vibrant
fun celebration
yeah
[Music]
you